This imaging system is designed
to have vision that works like our eyes do
These little lenses are used
to create images
with higher resolution in
the center than at the edges
Our eyes work the same way
thanks to a region
called the fovea,
which is rich in light receptors
Foveated electronic sensors can see a wide,
low-resolution view and
a narrower, high-resolution view
at the same time, instead
of one or the other
Which means
that this camera can capture a scene
at low and high resolution simultaneously
Having a wide view with
high resolution in the center
preserves detail where it’s needed
without sacrificing processing time
In the camera, a set of
four compound lenses
is 3D printed directly onto
an image sensing chip
Some of these lenses see from a wide angle,
while others take a narrower
view with higher resolution
The information from each
lens is digitally combined
to create a foveated image
with the most information
in the center
A foveated camera can do things like
helping self-driving cars make
quick judgments based
on visual information
At 300 square microns in size with lenses
only a few tens of microns across,
this camera is unique in its small
size and image quality
There’s still room to improve
the manufacturing time
and optical performance of this device
But it could be a boon to engineers
who need a device with
quick, sharp eagle eyes